Oh
first time I had a chance to meet a
whale and see a whale as whales see
whales underwater was in 1977 it was a
project that Roger Payne and I dreamed
up together I went to a conference in
New York listen to him talk he heard me
talking the same conference we felt we
had common ground I was really
interested in what he had to say about
whales he was really interested in the
thought that you might actually get into
the water with whales because I able
talk about exploring the ocean from the
inside out not just from the top down
and so he dreamed up this project to go
to Hawaii to work with humpback whales
the singing whales he and katie pain his
wife had really been listening to whales
from the surface trying to imagine what
it looked like when they do sing nobody
knew they hadn't been there to catch a
singing whale in action and to try to
correlate the sounds that they make with
the behaviors that they have so we put
together this project got the National
Geographic and California Academy of
Sciences in New York Zoological Society
survival anglia film company of other
supporters to weigh in to craft an
expedition that would take a big piece
of 1977 take us to Hawaii we had a boat
contributed we had fuel contributed we
had al giddings got engaged as a
filmmaker we had Peter tyack a graduate
student of peterson over Roger Paine's
and anyway this big expedition started
from a little conversation into a big
deal and the day came was the 13th of
februari 1977 without getting stuck
Nicklin and one other guy who's handling
the boat little rubber boat moving along
looking at a group of whales five of
them kind of cruising along and we just
tried to parallel them at a respectful
distance and then all at once the whales
decided they were going to come and
check us out so they did a sharp turn
and headed for a boat so we stopped the
boat and looked over the side and there
were
these whales upside down looking at us
but like giant swallows people see
pictures of whales in the old books you
look like buses loaves of bread they're
kind of static and like blocky creatures
but underwater they're like ballerinas
they're upside down right side up
turning and flying underwater they're
not stiff and blocky there there's slim
and beautiful and they dance we had
convinced all these supporters that what
we really wanted to do is to get in the
water with them see the whales on their
own terms to listen to their sounds and
correlate sound and behavior and then
came that moment when little tiny boat
little people and big whales looking
over the side there was no book of
etiquette that said this is what you're
supposed to do when you meet a whale
underwater so there's that little
hesitation maybe 30 seconds and then
over the wall over the side and here are
these creatures I mean I know I'm are
weigh 115 pounds of here are these
creatures that weighed 40 tons and you
know I'm five foot three they're 40 feet
long and what are you supposed to do was
up to them they came straight for us and
I couldn't get out of the way fast
enough so I just stayed there and let
whatever would happen happen and this
big female came right out of the blue
right for me and I thought it's up to
her what's going to happen what she did
was just sweet by close enough so I
could feel the wash as she went by and
his grapefruit sized I just tilted and
turned and she was checking me out and
then I saw her turn and go Toor dal
giddings big fins flippers 15 feet long
with an edge of barnacles along in front
of it like you know sharp barnacles if
she chose had chosen to take a swipe at
Al he might not have survived it but and
knowing that this was possible there
weren't any books to say otherwise
Chuck nickel and I started hooting
underwater or you know trying to warn
out that this whale was coming straight
for him because he was busy doing that
filmmakers do he was focused on that
other whale over there he didn't even
see her coming what happened just
changed everything as she approached she
did something remarkable instead of
decapitating him as she might have with
her big fin she just lifted it up over
she knew exactly where her body was she
had meant us no harm she was just
curious and did this sleep thing like
that and then I stopped worrying and I
started really engaging them engaging
myself in this get acquainted session
that went on for two and a half hours
they just kept circling around and
coming about five whales turns out we
now know the one female who first came
toward me at the time it was difficult
to tell for sure who was a male who was
a female but this was a big rotund
female we determined about to give birth
that's what those whales do when they
come to Hawaii he come to give birth
it's a nursery area they stay there for
a while until they leave to make the
journey back up to in this case the
Arctic waters for feeding and the others
are likely to have been males the the
years of study that have followed
suggests that what we were seeing is is
a chase males after a female trying to
engage her and we were just a part we
were incidental to this but we were
wide-eyed incidental and they were
curious they diverted enough to from
their other business to make us part of
their business and that's it that's the
thing you go into the ocean and if you
just let things happen you think you can
script a scene about what you want to do
I'm going to go film sharks well good
luck they'll do what they want to do you
are there as as a witness as a guest in
a way and I'm never disappointed but I
never try
to make things happen according to some
plans he'd give it up the plan is to go
and be surprised